hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to case animatronics
now we're trying to survive until 3 a.m.
and I actually just remembered that I
forgot the thing in the safe immediately
behind me and cat is still crawling
around so I need to oh wait that's not
open yet I need to go places ok so how
will I know when 3 a.m. is at least my
flashlights back up and working I just
need to not use it all the time
sure okay so I got my flashlight so I'll
wait this isn't the way to the control
room the control rooms the other way
dammit god dammit I got scared away
because probably wolfy was stomping
around over here see I know how to
survive I just got to be more mindful of
the sounds and be more ready to hide and
cower in fear like little [ __ ] that
hello oh you didn't see nothing right
you didn't see nothing huh you're fooled
cuz you're dumb and ugly oh oh oh
hey what what no no no no come on no
come on talk that's dumb it's dumb and
that's dumb
that's dumb in it dumb I'm dumb that
it's dumb that's dumb so dumb because
somewhere in there oh come on he was
silent
he wasn't my Banga oh god oh god okay
it's not
yep
he's gonna do it [ __ ] he bout to do it
that's how good we are back come on what
happened did he come out of a vent
[ __ ] behind me so I think I got it
come on no okay I thought I was dead
I thought a hundred percent I was dead
because that's so strange that as he's
dropping he can spot you I don't know
maybe he knows where you are and he
drops in spots at the same time I have
no idea
starting to get hallucinate 'add crazy
is he still in here no he can't be
starting to get bad I gotta get out of
this room goddamnit are they all just
gonna cycle back that way towards the
door goddamnit I gotta get
maybe if I go into this room it'll be
better it's better no this all counts is
the same room doesn't oh god it is okay
I gotta go [ __ ] [ __ ] it won't leave
me alone then won't leave me alone they
won't leave me alone
thank you
good God finally okay so I got to get to
another room don't just drop down
damnit man so how do I get better do I
get better at all or doing my suppose am
I supposed to somehow know the passcode
how would I know that
how'd are you charging weights Jesus
okay it's that a hundred percent so
where would it be where would there be a
passcode can't stop [ __ ] Christ no
okay okay so the desk is more effective
than the Wardrobe that's what we've
discovered where would there be like
we're in here would be a code that's not
at all evident to me where there'd be a
code to turn the ventilation system back
on or maybe the key is to get you know
the ventilation system back up maybe
that's what the key from surviving for
so long is it sounded far away ya know
it was behind me really it was behind me
really is that how this works it was it
was just behind me hanging out is that
how this works
yeah mother it was just hanging out
behind me huh hello hi that one is still
dancing around that big room which is
kind of good that means that he's at
least away
but I hear like the cat is literally
only thumping around me where is it
though I hear in purring and that's
lovely
where is I don't even see me under the
desk over there are not good sighs I
need to get out of this room okay
[ __ ] I don't know where I don't know oh
[ __ ] I don't know where uh wolfy went oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
god damn it I need to get out of this
room I can't be in these rooms
I'm way to gone I'm dead oh do not come
in this room please go away anywhere but
here
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you don't look back
okay we're in here now soulfully who's
gonna cool down a little bit and let us
recalibrate some of our brain juice
because it's all easing out of our ears
at this point okay
nopes vision still seems to be slightly
disturbed
god dammit see I have no way of knowing
how the [ __ ] 1984
I don't know how would I know there's no
way of knowing it's all just bad oh god
damn no no no no no no ah do not please
just don't don't leave me alone iron
this one iron this one please
oh come on the wardrobes never works
they just never work they never work
they never work they never work what's
the point
he probably just fell from a god [ __ ]
damn it are you kidding me
there's no metric of knowing there's no
metric what the [ __ ] kind of mechanic
I'm actually pissed at this what kind of
mechanic is it wait until 3:00 a.m.
we're not gonna tell you what time it is
when I got to tell you what to do do you
need to fix the ventilation maybe I
don't know [ __ ] it there's a code to do
it but I don't know why SWAT what is
with that like appearing and then not
appearing it's in there maybe because
it's crawling around the fence like it
doesn't render properly it wasn't there
that's good was that okay so there you
are so you're all the way in the other
area down there so I just got a cat man
chasing me down I'm pretty dicey in here
so eventually I'll need to move to this
area I just can't do it until
Wolfman has cleared it which looks like
he might have yeah oh that yeah that's
good okay
and he's jittery is [ __ ] hello
yes he's in here man he got there quick
what is they move faster when you're
looking at the camera for some reason
they jump all over the place this
doesn't make any sense
yeah but either way [ __ ] he's coming in
this room cut down sounds near me all
there is and so he's just going through
the offices now which is fine I'm
assuming anyway
I hear that it's lovely yeah I hear you
somebody thumb teleport thump them
where'd you go wow where did you go he's
just [ __ ] it oh there is so like it is
it is that is the case like watching him
makes him accelerate to his next
destination okay so should be good to
get out of here here for a spell
oh no there's a dead end I should be I'm
gonna is the ventilation really gonna
just let me go okay I must hold on until
3:00 a.m. I need that key you said that
already
this all autosave good did I get
something hi hi friend how you doing
thank goodness it autosave because
honestly [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you in case
it wasn't clear enough first time so did
I get it am i halfway there
am i having fun yet alright guess I just
pop out of here and charge and get under
the table
[ __ ] Oh fault goddamn teleported when I
was looking at the what what is that
what is that what is that well I have
the key card now what excuse me what
what hello hi were you what a plumber
oh okay yeah okay yeah all right okay
fine
you have met another one of my creation
yeah the guy on the other side your luck
surprises me I don't know okay
that's it no more playing around so this
was all just fun and going on a hunt
turn around surprise hi for you do not
walk away from the owl while she sees
you oh okay well that's good so what do
I do
yeah use the battery pack to turn on the
radio I don't know if I have a battery
pack so am I just supposed to stay here
forever what am I
what am I supposed to do what am I about
to do hi want to be friends it literally
said do not walk away from the owl when
it's easy what happens if I move huh
okay
so the radio was over here right do I
somehow have a battery pack no no do not
ah
Wow okay geez um x' hi oh hello sorry
didn't mean to interrupt
yeah you have a good one use the battery
pack to turn on the radio I don't have a
battery pack I ain't got one are you
talking about I figured like jumped what
I think it like jump me forward a bit in
the game maybe it took pity on me
finally so what am I supposed to do
about that owl is it just gonna sneak up
randomly and where the hell do I get a
battery pack I don't know half the
things you're telling me about maybe I
gotta get the battery pack from behind
that hole oh whoa hey hi how are you
doing didn't mean to do that okay
goodbye
okay alright you know what I'm done I
can't do this episode anymore I made
progress which is pretty good so in the
next episode I'm gonna try to find a way
to get through this even though it's
nondescript and the lack of direction is
killing me but I'm getting through it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video buh-bye